our robots really helping robots are
absolutely helping so the robot industry
has been around for 30 40 years pretty
focused in the car industry there is a
new class of robot and that's the class
that we're bringing it to market and
that is robots that are simple easy to
use inexpensive it could do a broad set
of manufacturing tasks and that is going
to bring a much much bigger robot market
there or set of applications into the
robot market Steven yeah I think that
we're seeing a renaissance of
applications for robotics companies like
a rethink are producing robots that can
operate in and among people and address
the ninety percent of all manufacturing
activities that are currently not
automated we have robots that companies
like Tesla and SpaceX that make them
much more productive but they're doing
the dangerous high-speed tasks that we
imagine in those factory robots the all
the other places where people are
putting things in boxes or loading or
unloading machines all those jobs that
are very repetitive or those tasks
ninety percent of lemon manufacturing
him not banana me think of the Isle of
Lucy's scene where she's working on the
conveyor belt that is exactly so Scott
what why was it why was it automotive
for so long and only automotive for so
long Scott well the technology has
changed quite a bit so what we had
before were essentially expensive very
precise and inflexible machines because
that was the state of Technology they
were a class of mainframes when the
market really wanted a Mac and what
exists today is cheap sensors cheap
computation widely available
connectivity and the ability to make a
software driven robot and that creates a
whole different world of robotics and
that's what rethink robotics is all
about it also seems to me that your
reprogram ability of your stuff the fact
that you know use the mac as an example
you can use the mac for a lot of things
you can do it to crunch a spreadsheet
you can make a precise little
presentation you can play a video game
and it doesn't take a lot of work for
the user to go from one to the next to
reprogram or
different programs is that sort of the
key to the future Scott that is a
critical part of its a great point so a
typical robot the type you see in the
automotive industry they take 200 hours
to program our robots take about two
hours and a typical non-expert can
program and operate the robot and
remember as Steve mentioned earlier
they're interacting side by side with
the robot right in the manufacturing
floor so it's there directly
manipulating the arm and easily training
the robot that means you can take a
robot from one job to another you can
automate small production runs which is
what you see in today's flexible
manufacturing you can also get into
small and medium business and there have
been almost no robots in small/medium
manufacturing up till now so it's a
dramatic expansion of where robots can
be used and who can use it you know when
you say it's easily programmed I can be
a testament to that my son at the age of
12 programmed the rethink robot that I
bought on a whim much like an apple
really Macintosh or an apple too it's in
our office and you program it by just
moving the arms you don't use a keyboard
you don't code you just say arm goes
here grabs cup you know or rather you
move it so you teach it to tactile
motion which anyone can do without any
training and so that just makes it
incredibly easy for any business to
consider take it out of the box plug it
in the 110 outlet get it to work and I'm
kind of curious where you're seeing this
up taken around the world is it you know
in the heartland of America is it
overseas where do you where do you find
most of the interest in this product
well it's actually in lots of different
markets so we have focused as a company
first on American manufacturing and we
have lots of robots and plastics
manufacturing metal manufacturing
consumer goods packing and packaging
even some warehousing and packaging
applications we have a lot of new
interest from international markets for
the same sort of vertical markets as
well as for some electronics
manufacturing a whole new industry that
has to use very few robots so far I want
to talk really briefly a year there in
mass and I want to talk about iRobot you
know company that they came to market
I don't know maybe 10 years ago with the
sort of similar promise of
revolutionising robotics bringing
robotics into the home having an
enormous growth and lots of different
sectors and you know it's a business
that did what in a five hundred million
dollars in sales last year it's up a
little bit I guess over its historically
but not a lot most of the markets they
have gone into they've generally failed
at at least a failed to get them any of
any size and and it's it's still really
a vacuum cleaner company and now now
about to face competition from the
vacuum king in Dyson with it with a
Dyson 360 what if what is this struggles
I won't calm a total field where one of
the struggles of irobot taught us about
the business scott be so I I don't I
can't comment to specifically on iRobot
although i would i would point out that
not only they revolutionized the the
vacuum cleaner they also revolutionized
bomb-disposal robots for for military
settings and that was an enormous market
when we had to ground wars going on with
the lesson you can learn from iRobot
that much of the new generation of
robots like like rethink robotics are
using is software driven sensor driven
robots and ease of use and Corey you
said you've got a Roomba yeah I'm push
one button wife anxious that's pretty
anyway it was a note note to marry guys
not really a great Christmas president
honey it's a robot vacuum it's not just
a vacuum cleaner for Christmas hmm still
a failure at Christmas but yes I have
the thing I like it my boy refuses to
use the thing is you know it's it's it's
just another vacuum cleaner
but it's a you know what they often say
about robots is once you stop calling it
a robot and you start calling it a
vacuum cleaner or whatever it might be
then it's successful because the idea of
it being something different is out of
your head and now it's a tool for you
it's a tool for vacuum cleaner and
successful I mean we see the same thing
in in our manufacturing customers they
they stop thinking about our Baxter
robot as some strange piece of
automation and it's it's part of the
manufacturing team they give them names
they put their you know their company
t-shirt on it they put the school sign
on it and it becomes part of the factory
team that's when you've really adopted
the robot as a co-worker that is helping
the lay of the employees in the factory
to be successful